after all these years it's easy to
assume we've learned everything there is
to know about director Christopher
Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy but just
like Batman himself these movies are
very good at keeping their secrets
Batman and Superman are often presented
in stark opposition to one another one
is a dark figure who triumphs through
technology and intimidation
the other is a bright hero who triumphs
through superpowers and inspiration with
that in mind it might be surprising to
hear that Christopher Nolan's Batman
actually owes quite a bit to the Man of
Steel no one has said that like many
people he was blown away by Richard
Donner Superman the movie in 1978 among
its many brilliant features he
appreciated that it told the full story
of Superman's origin
no one contrasted this with Tim Burton's
1989 Batman film in which the character
is fully formed by the time the movie
starts and saw Batman Begins as his
chance to do Batman in the style of
Superman 78 a movie where he could start
with a more recognizable setting
grounded in reality with a single
extraordinary figure in it and as the
title implies explore that hero's
beginnings while the shape of the
current slate of modern DC films comes
from the clash between Batman and
Superman
Nolan's masterful trilogy could never
have started without the inspiration of
the Big Blue Boy Scout well I certainly
hope this little incident hasn't put you
off flying miss statistically speaking
of course it's still the safest way to
travel one of the most notable aspects
of Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy is how
much Christian Bale made the character
his own he was after all the seventh
actor to Don the costume for the big
screen going all the way back to the 40s
and he knew it was inevitable that he'd
be compared to previous Batman all of
which makes it that much more
fascinating that when Bale auditioned
for the role of Batman he did so while
wearing Val Kilmer's old Batman suit
from Batman Forever
in fact Nolan made every prospective
Batman after wear the old suit why go
through all the trouble according to the
director being Batman on screen
transcended concepts such as chemistry
or simple acting ability instead he
needed an actor who would be believable
and compelling without being
overshadowed by the iconic imagery that
made Batman who he is or in other words
he really just needed a guy who looked
good in the suit no wonder Bale did so
many pushups without a doubt viewers
first glimpse of Harvey Dent's burned
face is appropriately grisly I'm sorry
[Music]
now
no you're not the amount of damage is
horrifying and it gives us a powerful
glimpse of the monster he's become as he
dispenses his brand of random coin based
justice against those who've wronged him
because of how utterly gross two-face
ended up looking it's surprising to hear
Christopher Nolan admit that he was
originally going to be even more
repulsive in an interview Nolan
characterized the final choice for two
faces appearance as one of the ones
least likely to disturb fans why is that
call it the uncanny valley effect
according to Nolan they tried versions
that were a little less gory but they
wound up being too realistic and way too
disturbing he made the apt comparison to
the Pirates of the Caribbean movies
noting that the way the undead were
rendered in those films used a less
realistic more exaggerated style that
ultimately made the imagery quote more
powerful and less repulsive in the Dark
Knight Heath Ledger gave such a powerful
and singular performance as the Joker
that it's still difficult to imagine
anyone else in the role even after
seeing Joaquin Phoenix's compelling
performance in Joker nonetheless even
Ledger's performance had its precedents
much of the Dark Knight trilogy
selectively draws from comics lore and
for the Dark Knight one major element of
the Joker's plan is taken from The
Killing Joke by comics legend Alan Moore
and Brian Bolland go that comic is
infamous for a number of reasons The
Joker paralyzes and assaults Barbara
Gordon and kidnaps Commissioner Gordon
taking him to a demented funhouse where
he's tortured with images of what the
Joker's done to his daughter why do all
this to break Batman's most dedicated
Ally proving that everyone is only one
disastrously bad day away from becoming
his twisted as he is sound familiar
it should in Dark Knight Ledger's Joker
gives two boats one filled with average
citizens and one filled with prisoners
with the capacity to blow each other up
he Gamble's that the so-called regular
people will give in to their base
impulses and killed dozens of people to
save themselves in both cases though
he's proven wrong in the comics Gordon
retains his sanity and the citizens and
prisoners of the movie don't descend
into becoming killers another comic book
series that heavily contributes to the
Dark Knight is Jeff lobe and Tim sails
1996 miniseries Batman the long
Halloween a story that unfolds over the
course of a year early in Batman's
career Batman James Gordon and
as yet unscarred Harvey Dent form an
alliance to take down Gotham's organized
crime the first issue ends on Halloween
night when Batman and dent find where
the mobs secret cash storages and burn
it all to a crisp a scene that gets a
nod in the dark night when the Joker
burns huge stacks of cash in the belly
of a ship by the end of the miniseries
it's clear a new kind of criminal has
risen in Gotham to replace the mop in
the final issue almost all of Batman's
more well known villains unite in a
final assault on mob boss Sal Maroni
'he's home
it's two-face who eventually kills
Maroni just as he does in the dark night
we hear echoes of this shift from
mobster to supervillain in the dark
night particularly during the
interrogation scene when Joker talks
about how Batman has changed Gotham I
know the truth there's no going back
you've changed things forever it's
implied in both the movie and in the
long Halloween that it's Batman's very
existence that leads to this escalation
but the main inspiration comes in how
both the movie and the comic chronicled
the fall of the idealistic Harvey Dent
and the birth of two-face Christopher
Nolan and his brother Jonathan who
co-wrote The Dark Knight Rises admitted
to drawing inspiration from a seemingly
unlikely source Charles Dickens classic
A Tale of Two Cities
in retrospect though it seems a bit
obvious at the end Commissioner Gordon
even reads from the book at Bruce
Wayne's funeral it is a far far better
thing that I do
than I have ever done in a tale of two
cities one man about to be executed
Charles Darnay is saved when his
identical double Sydney Carton takes his
place but not before carton waxes
philosophic about the beautiful city and
brilliant people who are rising from the
abyss sounds a little familiar right the
one big difference is that the death in
the film ends up being more symbolic as
its Batman who dies so Bruce Wayne can
lead a happy normal life in addition to
drawing from Dickens The Dark Knight
Rises mashes up several different comic
story lines it borrows one basic concept
from The Dark Knight Returns in which an
aging Bruce Wayne comes out of
retirement to deal with a Gotham that's
only gotten worse in his absence while
Bruce Wayne isn't eligible for the
senior citizen discount in this movie
the earlier narrative does make a big
deal of what it's like for Wayne to
return to the role of a hero after eight
years of retirement the movie also
brings in elements of nightfall the
story arc in which Bane discovered who
Batman really was and after weakening
him by unleashing arkham asylum inmates
on the city broke into Wayne Manor and
broke his back in the comics Batman was
out of commission for quite a while with
Caped Crusader duties being taken over
by the unstable character of Azrael the
final comic inspiration was no man's
land a story that saw Gotham City
impacted by an enormous earthquake in
response the government and one can only
assume they were just waiting for a
chance to do something like this
destroyed all bridges into Gotham and
prevented other access to it declaring
the entire city on no-man's land
citizens can't get out and the villains
decide to take over the movie inverts
this of course with Bane and his crew
cutting the city off but the narrative
of trying to survive in isolation and
surrounded by psychopaths remains it's
tough at this point to imagine Batman
without Nolan's trilogy however before
he brought the world into focus with
Batman Begins there were a number of
false starts while Warner Brothers spent
a decade trying to figure out where they
wanted to take the franchise an explicit
live-action adaptation of The Dark
Knight Returns was scrapped and Batman
year one was nearly adapted twice
amusingly one of these scrapped movies
included Batman vs. Superman which very
nearly came out in 2004
perhaps the weirdest movie planned was
the studio's second attempt at a Batman
year one adaptation it would have been
directed by Darren Aronofsky famous for
movies such as wreck
for a dream with a screenplay by
Aronofsky and Batman year one comic
writer Frank Miller in the story Bruce
Wayne is a poor kid taken in and raised
by a mechanic on the wrong side of the
tracks
he becomes an unhinged vigilante in the
style of taxi drivers Travis Bickle
later in inspiration for 20 19's Joker
the story was also set to feature an
unhinged violent and somewhat suicidal
Jim Gordon
fortunately the project was axed paving
the way for our familiar Dark Knight
trilogy to unfold months before Ledger's
death Christian Bale praised his
co-stars commitment to his role during
an interview referencing the scene when
Batman confronts Joker in the GCPD
interrogation room they'll told THR that
Heath Ledger insisted that he hit him
for real apparently the physical
punishment didn't end with the beating
Leger took Bale went on to describe
ledger quote slamming himself around and
there were tiled walls inside of that
set which were cracked and dented from
him hurling himself into them throughout
the Dark Knight trilogy the most
noticeable casting change is Bruce
Wayne's old friend and love interest
Rachel Dawes created specifically for
the film trilogy and not appearing in
the comics Dawes is played by Katie
Holmes and Batman Begins but is replaced
by Maggie Gyllenhaal in The Dark Knight
the change led to speculation that
Holmes whose performance wasn't met with
the most enthusiastic reviews was the
victim of harsh critics Christopher
Nolan denied this saying Holmes simply
was not available for the Dark Knight it
took 8 years but Holmes finally broke
her silence about it to confirm her
absence in the Dark Knight was her own
choice and went on to praise Gyllenhaal
for doing quote a wonderful job she
didn't explain her reasons for leaving
the franchise though maybe she just
didn't want to be blown up by an evil
clown as for Gyllenhaal she wanted to be
sure that it was Holmes decision too she
reportedly reached out to ask for Holmes
blessing before giving a firm yes to
replacing her as Rachel Dawes
Christopher Nolan is known for going to
great lengths to keep plot points of his
film secret and the Dark Knight trilogy
was no exception how does no-one achieve
this level of secrecy well apparently he
tells his actors the bare minimum they
need to know ask Liam Neeson he tapped
Neeson to reprise his role as Ra's al
Ghul for a cameo in 2012
Dark Knight Rises and apparently told
the actor absolutely nothing about the
film he later said in an interview that
it wasn't that he didn't want to discuss
the plot but that he couldn't because he
literally didn't know anything about it
Neeson may have only had a small part in
Dark Knight Rises but as the butler
Alfred Pennyworth Michael Caine was a
significant part of Batman Begins and he
got similar treatment when asked to
appear Caine said that Nolan appeared at
his door personally with the draft for
Batman Begins and asked if he was
interested in playing Alfred Nolan just
sat there while Caine read the script
and then took it with him when he left
over the years a handful of actors have
given us memorable performances as
Alfred Pennyworth
but while tastes will always differ
you'd have a rough time arguing that
anyone has done a better job of
embodying Alfred than Michael Caine the
actor gave us an Alfred who would go to
any lengths to support Bruce Wayne's
efforts to save Gotham while at the same
time desperately wanting nothing more
than for Wayne to give up the cowl and
cape so he can find some true commitment
surprisingly it came close to not
happening in fact Caine has admitted
that when he was initially approached
about the role as Alfred he was not at
all enthused saying quote I thought that
wasn't a very good part I'll be saying
dinner is served
and would you like a coffee presumably
Caine was thinking of previous versions
of the character like the late Michael
Gough of the Tim Burton Joel Schumacher
films whose portrayal of the character
showed no signs of ever hunting jewel
thieves in the jungles of Burma
can I persuade you to take a sandwich
with you sir I'll get drive-thru
thankfully Caine learned no one had
bigger plans for his character although
his early hesitation became a running
joke between him and Noland he told The
Huffington Post that in 2011 Nolan sent
him a Christmas present a dinner gong
with dinner is served engraved on it one
enduring superhero trope is the hero
having to fight some kind of reflection
of himself like Iron Monger in Iron Man
or the Yellow Jacket in ant-man or a lot
of Marvel movies actually well shortly
after the release of the Dark Knight
Batman was called out by Batman or the
real Batman No in November 2008 Variety
reported that the town of Batman Turkey
was suing Christopher Nolan and Warner
Brothers for using the town name without
permission there was no explanation as
- why then Batman mayor Hussein kalkan
was not also suing DC Comics Tim Burton
Joel Schumacher or anyone else involved
in the numerous Batman television shows
movies and animated series over the
years however Kalkan did level some
ridiculous sounding charges at the dark
night including blaming its influence
for unsolved killings in the area
there's no word on the outcome of the
mayor's efforts though we have a tough
time believing we wouldn't have heard
something if the lawsuit went anywhere
significant we do however know that at
least one part of the country has
patched things up with the Caped
Crusader Turkish Airlines had some
significant product placement in Batman
vs Superman and even used Bruce Wayne in
an ad announcing Gotham City as their
newest destination in other words
customers in the DC Universe can now fly
to Batman with Batman Nestor Carbonell
who appears as the mayor of Gotham in
both the Dark Knight and the Dark Knight
Rises has a singular distinction in the
Dark Knight trilogy like Christian Bale
he also played Batman kind of more of a
parody of Batman before the Dark Knight
trilogy there was the Fox networks 2001
live-action version of the tick based on
the superhero spoof comic of the same
name by Ben Edlund among the tix allies
in the show was Batman well played by
carbonelle like Batman Batman well
doesn't appear to have any kind of
superpowers unlike Batman Batman well
also doesn't seem to have any other
abilities that make him good at fighting
crime as far as we know there were no
plans for the mayor of Gotham revealing
he was secretly planning to become a
Caped Crusader like Batman and that's
probably the best choice for everybody
you may recall the scene toward the
beginning of the Dark Knight when Bruce
Wayne goes to Lucius box for upgrades to
the bat suit specifically asking to be
able to move his head you'd think it
would be a fairly small thing to ask
right if you're constantly fighting
crowds of criminals and ninjas you
should be able to look around know the
1989 version of Batman couldn't do it
but this is the 21st century and super
suit technology has to have advanced a
little bit so it may surprise you to
learn that there's another very basic
function that Christian Bale's Batsuit
didn't often allow him to do breathe
Bale said that the cowl was so tight
that he would have to take it off after
every couple of takes just to catch his
breath which might explain why he had
such a hard time fighting
apparently this was a bigger problem
during the production of Batman Begins
than it was on the set of The Dark
Knight Rises though it seems that by
2012 Wayne Industries finally mastered
the fine art of making clothes that
won't strangle the people wearing them
in the Dark Knight
Batman's journey to Hong Kong doesn't
last that long but it's arguably the
most controversial sequence of the
entire film in 2007 Christopher Nolan
denied reports that he changed the dark
night because of Hong Kong water
pollution an unnamed member of the
production team had said that originally
Batman was supposed to jump out of an
airplane into Hong Kong's Victoria
Harbour but that was changed when the
team tested the water and found it to be
full of contagious diseases
the following week Nolan said he was the
one who changed the script but that it
had nothing to do with water pollution
quipping that as a director he wouldn't
mind dipping his actors into a little
dirty water anyway a little over a year
later Warner Brothers announced the Dark
Knight would not screen in China and
that they hadn't even submitted the film
to government censors for consideration
the studio didn't elaborate but the
issues in question are widely believed
to revolve around the Hong Kong sequence
there's the simple fact that it involves
a Chinese money loaned her and then
there's the cameo from Edison Chen a
Hong Kong singer who at the time was
embroiled in a scandal involving
explicit photos leaked on the web check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]